yo man blackhead podcast
we got young blue man aka blue van dross
in the building right now man
let's get it welcome oh yeah hey man i
got to give you some props man cause um
i feel like uh you're one of the first
artists that is
that kind of this new wave
is going on sonically you know yeah i
feel like you're one of the first
artists you've been doing the
extremely melodic you know romantic thug
[ __ ] for a very long time and i know
that that's like kind of
catching on like real big you know like
guys like rod wave and like you know
but i feel like you were one of the
first dudes i heard that really really
was like
oh this dude's like singing his ass off
and like it's some it's some other [ __ ]
like i think pnb rocks in that
conversation but i definitely think like
yeah
you're one of the early guys who like
that before the world
that that really before they really just
too much understood it
like they they really understood the
wave of that
right then you know since i was it was
it was hot in the streets
but like i was trying to get the major
label to believe in that way
you know what i'm saying and they ain't
really understanding at the time so
yeah i'm sure that they wish they would
have understood it now
yeah i just saw you post a picture with
two gold plaques
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah don't probably
look yeah they probably platinum i'm
waiting on my platinum plates now
yeah independently man yeah that shit's
a beautiful thing
um now help me okay let's clear up this
this this situation
i saw you just post that vlad headline
that was missing right
yeah so for people who don't know you
originally were signed
um i i think a lot of people were
introduced to you through boozy
yeah yeah yeah right you were on the
episode the the bupok album and
uh-huh um boozy was he the first guy who
really kind of like came in and
co-signed you as far as like
oh yeah for sure and coming out of
alabama i know how booze is not from
alabama
boozy in the south is like [ __ ] jesus
christ yeah himself or so
um so there was the headline had said
that you were no longer with boozy's
label and you're with dream chasers now
yeah okay and can you clear that whole
situation
up uh man that situation was just a
misunderstanding i
i really like how the headline looked
because it seemed like on some
switching teams type type stuff like i
said uh
you know just like the clip that he
posted
within like if you read the story it'll
show you that i said that i told that i
came to boost i was like i ain't really
like us
rocking with colombia no more because
you know they weren't really doing
what i needed them to do for me you know
what i'm saying so i was like
we was joint venture with them a lot of
people don't know that like i was joint
venture with
me boosting columbia records like six
months after i signed to him so
uh you know after about you know some
years just like i said they really
understand the wave i had going on so
i just felt like it was best to just go
independent and when i say independent
you know boosted labor independent you
know what i'm saying so
we independent you know what since i'm
trying to i ain't
switched to when i say i got off the
label i'm always talking about columbus
columbia
yeah i'm not talking about boosters are
you still signing the boosies yeah yeah
imprint yeah i'm still signing like we
just amended some
things like after that kaduna deal we
had to sit back i was a bigger artist
you know what i'm saying so we
amended some things you know i told him
like kind of like my vision
you know so no i think that's dope too
like
a lot of times right you signed that
deal early with an artist like you know
another artist yeah and like you know
hey man i'm at a different place now
let's let's the fact
and boozy was open to that conversation
yeah because it wasn't like no
it wasn't it wasn't like saying i'm at a
different place now i don't want to be
assigned to your label no more
right but like he could be he could be
an [ __ ] and be like look you signed
what you signed yeah that tells you how
real
how real of a [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's what i'm saying so you know we
amended some things you know boosters
still get his
percentage like just how the original
contract set up is just that you know
saying i own my masters and stuff like
that that's dope
and a lot of people don't know like [ __ ]
for that deal it's a lot of business
for that deal to get them in it's a lot
of business i did you know what i'm
saying to
to to get that to that point you know it
wasn't just
i mean we we good we fam but at the same
time like i gave up
all my like 100 of my
masters during that time to be able to
own a hundred percent of my future stuff
you know what i'm saying so i gave
booster like
all the mixtapes and stuff i dropped
with boosted like boosted like get out
of the masters yeah he owned a message
to those you know what i'm saying
so these so essentially you said hey you
could have these masters if you
just let me move the way i want to move
moving forward yeah because i had like
three four albums left with him so
it's like he could have said you know
what i'm saying no you know what i'm
saying like
from my own need too you know what i'm
saying but uh
like i said you know what i'm saying
like it was it was
it was willing to dylan you know what
i'm saying so not i mean look
i think you know there's
with with you know kanye's been on his
his [ __ ] lately with the groups of the
masters and just record deals and i
think
the major labels won't even let you do
that like you can't go i was gonna say
like i think that's some real [ __ ] when
like if you think of like boozy like you
know obviously you signed whatever you
signed
yeah and for him to be like open to just
like hey man look if
you're obviously in a different place
than when i met you yeah like let's move
differently moving forward yeah
and plus you know like i said the basic
of the contract
still the same you know what i'm saying
it's just that you know saying i i have
you know i could do what i want you know
what i'm saying
basically but you know he's still
getting the same now like if i go over
here
if i go sign with uh if i want to go
sign up i go sign with uh
atlantic and he's gonna get
y'all the next album blow up and sell a
million copies you know what i'm saying
he's still gonna get fifty percent of
that you know what i'm saying for the
same amount yeah fifty
damn he got the fifty all right because
that's what was the original contract i
got you i got you
and you owe him three or four more
albums uh yeah yeah yeah
so let me ask you this then what what
because i know meek fuss with you heavy
what is the actual
official affiliation so meek the meek
situation came about
um and also just the
the backtrack one one one thing like
go ahead the me booster situation okay
it's it's it's 50 of you know what i'm
saying
it's like a profit participation it's
like you know saying
uh you know i'm giving i'm giving you 50
because this this was the original
contract but
okay in the original contract then i
couldn't have been able to go
if somebody wanted to give me a million
dollars over here you know what i'm
saying i couldn't have
technically i couldn't sign that deal
you know what i'm saying now you can
yeah but now i can you so so i feel like
i
i gave up i had to give up something to
get able to
yeah because i know i'm a drop yeah i'ma
drop mo music i know i'm gonna drop
you bang out three or four projects in a
year if you're yeah you know what i'm
saying but
moving fast moving fast forward so we me
and him talked about the
the uh the meat situation you know meat
team uh
came to me you know sherry bryan them
over there uh that's actually the
president of the roc nation
so she came to me and it was just you
know laid out a situation on the table
to where
i felt like at the time made sense you
know it was a management situation
where she was just like you know we
could help you with a you know a lot of
stuff
of course uh and it was like
you know i looked it over we talked
about it for a couple months
i went i flew down that uh meet with me
and still i talked about it with booster
you know saying he felt like he was
you know what i'm saying it'll be good
because him and me good you know what
i'm saying so
that's what that situation was it wasn't
like no all right booster you know what
i'm saying
let me go over here to meet nah like
that
so meek's team is management yeah yeah
yeah yeah
that's what's up they're part of the
management how did um
how did mika like what would you know
like what the original record was that
like caught meek's attention or that
like
brought him made him a fan of yours i
think i think it was more of a
i think it was more meat team like it
was more meat team
you know what i'm saying presented to me
and then because they were like yo this
kid's moving we should work with him
like
yeah you know what i'm saying i i
honestly don't
i honestly don't really too much know if
you know because meek from a whole
different you know what i'm saying
another part of the
whole other part of the country so oh no
if you too much
just understand you know what i'm saying
my music so much
as of yet you feel me but i feel like
you know
i can't i came in for what i you know i
feel like his team you know
his team was presented to me and what
they could do you know so i ain't coming
to ride meek way you know ride his coat
till you know i came in for
i think that's just kind of the
misunderstanding i think is like people
just see it
people see a headline and that's what
they go with yeah you know what i'm
saying
so yeah it's important to clear that
[ __ ] up so um
you're from alabama man and alabama has
really
had a crazy like last like three or four
years
where like you know obviously back in
the day there was like dolby
and um yellow wolf and you know guys
like that and then
yeah rich boy and then even before that
i think there was a group called dirty
like you got dirty boys yeah yeah yeah
dirty was crazy remember that
the album cover was the guy that had a
snake
and and now it's like man one of the
hotbeds of hip-hop at the moment i feel
like it's like alabama
it's obviously baton rouge and it's
memphis
like those are the three cities that
have kind of always kind of been
traditionally
slept on and now y'all got it right now
like what was it harder coming out of
alabama
yeah because when i first started coming
out of alabama like i was the only one
so i had to try to make the whole
industry believe in alabama you know
what i'm saying because
you know that went i started coming up
right around the time like doe b
passed away you know what i'm saying so
he was plus like yellow wolf was doing
his own [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know it was back
to wolf but yeah it's definitely not the
same you know way yeah
it was in like the the street hip-hop
street [ __ ] yeah i'm going you know i'm
going to interview them
radio interviewing and you know saying
just getting everybody to try to believe
in this alabama
i'm a wave and then wants to you know
the other people started coming up
you know it was like okay yeah you know
what i'm saying it's it's
it's official so now it's like we got we
got more so
not everybody believe in it because it's
just like you looking from a small city
somewhere and one person
you know saying doing stuff from that
city right at that moment and you just
like
i don't know if i should believe in it
yet you know what i'm saying maybe he's
just lucky it didn't
yeah it was you and then like the mirror
caught on and yeah you know
but i don't think the middle man the
mill won't really rip and alabama yeah
he wouldn't yeah
he was snapping at the moment like that
so i can't really i can't really
uh i i feel like that came
after he saw more people
you know ripping it and then you know
saying he
eventually you always need your state
you feel me
eventually you're going to need it you
know you can't yeah so you can't
uh so yeah that's how i feel about what
what is um because i feel like you know
the unfortunate thing about
memphis and baton rouge that i've
noticed is like most of the major
artists all have beef with each other
yeah um is that is
what's what's your relationship like
with the your you know some of your
peers from alabama because there's a lot
of
yeah a lot of dudes man bubbling like is
everything pretty much solid or yeah i
mean
i mean of course there's always some
some screen stuff going on behind the
scenes of the music but
like far as me my situation like
everybody look at me as
you know i'm saying like really one of
the founders of that
like alabama new generation you know
what i'm saying
type [ __ ] so everybody really look up to
me and respect me like
i don't be for nobody ain't got no smoke
in the city like everybody
you know i miss flo milly cow rylo
uh you know everybody just just coming
up out of alabama like
i didn't even know if flo miller was
from alabama i knew i didn't know
capitals
like all all of all of the artists
that's popping from
alabama is from mobile a little bit like
that
that shit's like oh no no it's like
[ __ ] north
florida right yeah it's it's south it's
like
right right right right in mexico yeah
because yeah every time because i used
to live in tampa so when i would drive
yeah you would drive through mobile yeah
so you're from mobile yeah i'm from
mobile and what is
like the energy is there a big energy
difference between like birmingham and
because i think people always associate
birmingham alabama with alabama like
well i think we really different though
like you know say we real different of
course you know saying they got they
artists
that's doing anything you know i'm
saying is there is like a separation or
is it like yeah we repping the state or
is it like yeah i think i think
i think it's on some [ __ ] like we
repping the state you know saying they
got tirely cinco
little soldier you know saying other
type of orders i feel like you know
bad blood i feel like everybody just
ripping just glad we got this wave going
on
uh right now probably like a
you know we got the most artist that's
that that's big big right now in the
state but
i feel like eventually he's going to
start evening not you know
saying yeah like even like the dude
clevers from godson like yeah yeah
clever yeah clever clever popping right
now
yeah clever that's my boy too yeah shout
out to clever
um so
um you're invested
you had the mixtape series investments
which i thought was a dope like
yeah i feel like when people watch you
on social media they get a different
message and vibe from when they watch
most of these
young artists in the game because i feel
like you know a lot of type
of these new cats is like it's a lot of
antics on the gram like i feel like your
[ __ ] can be inspirational for a lot of
people
yeah um but investments i know you
you know you're smart with your bread
you learn like like
what are you doing during the pandemic
and just
in general with your money that you
don't think the average
rapper in your position is doing uh
through the whole pandemic i've been
building my house like i got a state
that i just built so
uh you know that's what i've been pretty
much and you got a baby on the way right
yeah yeah yeah uh she she's economy told
me uh she probably be going to label
like in the next couple of days though
so i gotta you gotta get him ready to
shoot yeah
are you still in alabama no no i live in
mississippi now
yeah alexi oh yeah i heard that the
taxes there are fire like you don't
gotta pay state taxes or something oh
no i ain't no no i heard that
like in texas you don't got to pay
stability
nah it's great you could live bro in l.a
if you had a house here you lived here
you'd be paying [ __ ] 30 percent
yeah that brother let me in your [ __ ]
pockets out here not but um
but like are you like investing in any
sort of like outside of your own house
like
any other stuff like oh yeah i got i
mean i got a food truck
uh i got a restaurant you know what i'm
saying uh
so that that picture you sitting on the
top of a restaurant that's your actual
restaurant yeah so your restaurant's
called
young blues no no it's called that was
before the rest of the sign came okay
it's a mixtape cover guys yeah young
blue soul food to seafood version
no it's really called gwen's house young
blues soulful
you got a food truck the restaurant what
else um
and you know i do you know what i'm
saying i do it's just a lot a lot of
different i got a lot of different
screens
income but i got a 12 bucks that i ran
out uh
when i'm not on it you know what i'm
saying so you got a tour bus you ran out
you're in the food truck space you got
the restaurant yeah
are you um first of all salute
yes so most artists are like yo let me
go get a maybach
yes here's all of my advance oh god i
got
i got that out the way when i was when i
was young before i even signed a deal
getting money from shows
like you got you got the dumb [ __ ] out
the way yeah i got that i'm glad i got
that afterwards yeah yeah yeah cause
otherwise you you know you're you're
like
leveraging your ship yeah in a bad way
but no so um
what about like have you tapped in with
like the stock market at all or any like
the crypto [ __ ] or
uh i've been i've been testing it out
like a little bit here a little bit
they're just trying to
get a feel for it but there's just so
much stuff going on with
this scamming and stuff like oh my god
it's like i'd be scared when they come
to me
i'll be like anytime someone hits you
and says hey can you use an extra 10
grand right now say no
yeah because they're just scamming the
[ __ ] hundreds i don't really think
i'm too much into this stock market
right now
it's too much yeah it's too much [ __ ]
nah you don't like to gamble no i don't
like the camera i respect that you got
to keep your money
what is the hardest thing you've learned
about being in the restaurant business
because i know it's a really hard
business to like
succeed in we always see restaurants
coming and going all the time yeah we
[ __ ] yeah we shut down right now because
of this cover stuff so we're going to
get ready to
come back up i'm gonna get ready to turn
into a club or hookah lounge but
uh the best thing i learned for real is
just that it's just
i ain't never really make no money from
my restaurant you know what i'm saying
like i
it was just open just for me like it was
i mean it was
it was lit it was like we made a lot of
money but it was so much overhead that
you really see a lot of money so you
like you ain't ain't no going into the
account oh i'm gonna take the ten
thousand and go do this you know
probably like if you touch that like you
might not be able to pay the bills next
month yeah you're feeling
even though they had a little cause you
know i'm an artist so i
a lot of times i just come out of my
pocket but when i started coming out of
my pocket i was like no
you know first i was just breaking even
oh i probably making a little money
you know what i'm saying probably
nothing like a thousand or two you know
what i'm saying but
i was satisfied with that because i was
like at least we you know
you're making money yeah you know what
i'm saying oh at least i just wanted to
have a restaurant like just some in my
city you know saying any matter if i was
just breaking even because i really
wanna
doing it for the prophet yeah so uh but
yeah once i started to come out of my
pocket you know what i said then we was
only in business like three months
before the kobe hit we were doing good
for the curve hit
so we was real fragile you know what i'm
saying so oh yeah that was just the
worst time people started catching cove
with them up in the
like auto workers stuff just this is
this is in this is in mobile yeah yeah
yeah yeah so i had
yeah i had i had to shut it down and
then once i shut it down people spout
new jobs and just a whole lot of stuff
so i'm just remodeling it right now
yeah i feel like i've heard though that
alabama uh being the
crazy right-wing redneck state that it
is most people
don't even act like the coverture is
real down there my boy was down there
for
labor day and he was like nobody's
wearing masks
they definitely like you know they they
they weird down there but i had this
thing called blue badge that i was
throwing
down i had everybody on it like you know
saying
uh 42 dogs free birthday yeah yeah no it
was for my album release part
uh but you just did was that recently uh
yeah but i did i ended up doing a little
show because they council
it was supposed to be at lab people
stadium i had like 20 artists pnb rock
right i had everybody in the game they
really black youngster
lucha everybody they mess with me for
real they can't figure it out
yeah but they came back and started
throwing football games at the same
place and i'm like
so that was like a big thing with the
news and stuff they was trying to get me
to get political and stuff like that but
i really wanted too much do it right
then because i know i'm going to throw
it again and i want to throw it
you know what i'm saying i ain't really
want to stir up i know i could have
stirred up you don't want to stir it up
because it might [ __ ] up like next year
if you want to do it at the same place
yeah
yeah i i feel like i was just going to
lift them heavy because
the cover you know saying the cover
stuff you know it's probably
would have been hard for me to win
against that right what [ __ ]
where is the university of alabama the
university oh that's in tuscaloosa ah
that is tuscaloosa yeah you're right
yeah yo it's crazy it's like college
football like as big in mobile as it is
like because it's like a
it's like religion down there bro yeah
yeah yeah it's b
everything alabama no no alabama
roll tide bro yeah sec football it's
like a religion now
oh it's insane is the whole state just
like roll tide like
banging that or is there yeah most
people worldwide it's auburn in alabama
yeah armament orbiting alabama yep damn
that's crazy yeah the the kovitch [ __ ]
is crazy but i do know in the south
they're a little like uh
yeah more liberal with not wearing masks
and
you know did you happen to watch the
presidential debate yesterday
uh yeah i was watching a little bit on
twitter yeah what do you what do you
think of uh
the elect i mean you know you're a smart
guy man what are your thoughts on the
election and
and where the [ __ ] our world is
currently at because
uh i think i think you know what i'm
saying
just watching it i feel like you know
saying biden was making uh
way more valid points i just i just felt
the more caring vibe from
from biden then than trump like trump
just like don't give a [ __ ]
don't don't give a [ __ ] you know this
was like the six nine of [ __ ]
politics bro he just
say whatever the [ __ ] it like you like
it don't matter if it's true like he's
just throwing [ __ ] at the wall
yeah you feel me so i feel like if i had
to vote i'd probably
vote buying just because like he's like
because he's not an insane
racist bastard yeah just i can't
i can't do it i can't deal with you have
you have you ever voted
nope do you plan on voting uh
yeah i do plan on voting like you know
saying one day
you know saying well look we got a month
man you better register go get go
go get that alabama vote in that's
that's a red state yeah
yeah i'll probably i'll probably vote
yeah you should man
yeah i don't want to say no because i
feel like people gonna follow me and not
vote
listen bro at the end of the day that
people
will find if people [ __ ] hate you
yeah they'll watch this and find
five minutes that that they can it just
is what it is there's miserable
[ __ ]
it's it's unfortunate um i have
you know being as somebody you know it's
crazy because like i said earlier like i
feel like people know you for your
music yeah period
and not for like oh this guy was beefing
or this guy was [ __ ]
on instagram you know flashing guns and
like
like i feel like your music is what
is like like and and i think that's why
you're what you're going on like your
fifth year in this [ __ ] right that's
already longevity
and that's crazy to say but if you see
the way artists come and go
dude like people can't last two years
out here before their [ __ ] is like a
wrap and you haven't even
sniffed like commercial success like you
have but like you're not even like
your [ __ ] is really underground like for
like obviously for being someone who's
got plaques
yeah yeah yeah yeah i know i understand
what you're saying perfectly because i
you know i'm saying i think about it all
the time you know but i just
i just know like when that moment come
it's going to be
huge because i put so much groundwork in
like it it's nothing going to be like it
came from overnight you know what i'm
saying people just going to be like
y'all just getting on him like yeah like
he been he been doing this like he been
had you know
saying local hits regional hits not a
mainstream hit so i feel like that's
that that's way better because they
don't take number one year turnaround to
you know what i'm saying to for real to
and uh
i think the i'm in now you know saying
it's gonna be way better for me because
i got
you know uh i feel like i'm
like i said i'm a student of the game so
i i just
learned i learned everything i got my
money right you know what i said so it's
gonna be a whole new
and i could move when i want to you know
i ain't got to wait on nobody so
it's going to be a whole different way
what was the gift in the curse because
we always hear about like signing to
other artists and i do think boozy
doesn't get enough
respect as a ceo you know his label is
doing its thing but what was the gift
and the curse being signed to another
artist
uh i say the uh
me it really would i i feel like it's
all on the artist you know what i'm
saying it's all an order like
it's all it's it's about how hard case
by case
yeah you know what i'm saying cause it's
like somebody can sign you to
they label you could be the biggest
artist in the world you know what i'm
saying
and but
what you gonna do once you get signed
that you know i think that's where a lot
of people make a mistake is they sign
and then they're like okay then they
just wait on on on them
and that's what as opposed to like nah
now you got to roll your [ __ ] sleeves
up so you'll get down and really get to
work
yeah because you can't depend on nobody
for your own [ __ ] ever
control your own destination and most of
the time the artists you know they had
they
own stuff going on too so it's like they
can't they probably could be focused on
you but they gonna always be focused on
you so the time that they not
they probably be working on the album or
they probably got some personal stuff
going on
that they can't really give all their
time to you so you got to
roll up your sleeves and turn up so that
was the thing that was different from me
like
when i got in things in your own hands
yeah like you know i took that co-sign
and ran ran once and did my thing so
like if you ain't really got that in you
then you probably just go
you know i'm saying just be on beyond
and i'm like i won't really
around boosted like i used to be around
boosted
and i still be around them but i just
went like around them every day like i
used to go do my
own stuff you know as i make my own
name for myself and then came back like
yeah you know what i'm saying talk about
what you've learned from boozy because
we were talking earlier
and i was like you would tell me you
were shooting a video in l.a and i was
like who's the artist and you were like
you know somebody who just bagged you
out yeah yeah and um
you know i know boozy whatever city he's
in yeah
he's pull up have your money right and
you get in the verse and you were saying
that you kind of do something similar
and i
you know i think that there's a couple
of ways to look at that i think
some people might be like you might
water down your value but at the same
time
like you're an independent artist and
you don't know if this is as good as
it's gonna get
yeah yeah so you might as well get every
bag you can right now
yeah i mean like i said i used to worry
about like
yeah booster kind of taught me that you
know what i'm saying i used to worry
about
how it would look you know i'm saying if
i posted this
i posted that but i mean you gotta look
at it like
people gonna talk regardless you know
what i'm saying like
and then and and my point of view is
like
yeah people are going to talk with girls
so you might as well get it why because
when it's over with yeah
what's your run over with you you know
what i'm saying
like right like get every dollar you can
offer your
while it's hot you know what i'm saying
cause when it's not hot
people ain't gonna care people ain't
gonna care what you guess what if i go
do
if i go post i'm doing features right
now and like the next week
i post that i made a 100k i'll feature
get what everybody said
get what everybody's saying you know
what i'm saying everybody you know said
co-signing that like people want to do
that you know what i'm saying so
it ain't no bad thing but like people
don't talk regardless man get get your
coin especially if you put in all these
years of work
i saw a quote today was like you know
i'm saying
it probably take me 30 minutes to do a
job right now
and make all this money but the years
and years that i put in before that you
ain't see that you know what i'm saying
so you paying me for them years you feel
you ain't paying me for this 30 minutes
i came to the studio you paying
me for all these everything to get that
and then plus like
like i said bro you know what i'm saying
i'm gonna eat i know people do
way more but like i said i screamed
started meeting
screens every two months you know what
i'm saying so i
i deserve it you feel me so what do you
uh like respect
let's say somebody you know who you
don't know maybe you don't [ __ ] with the
song let's say the song is trash yeah
and you're in [ __ ] oklahoma city
oklahoma yeah
what is that what is the what is the uh
what if i what if
i want to hook what's that cost uh
man
he's a juggalo he's the icp guy hey man
like my
my prices my price i mean most times
if the song transfer i personally think
the song treasures you know saying i
just make my part hard
you just go fast i guess you're gonna
fast forward to my part you know as well
you gonna
listen to the whole song for my part you
feel me if the song trends but
like i said it's so many fans out there
people who like all type of music but
it could be trash to me but somebody
don't like it
you gotta listen to what people listen
to okay so let's give me the menu man
what's the hook what's the hook menu
what's this
it's just it's just it just depends like
right now like for like for a hook
like if i'm if i'm probably in the city
oh i'll probably try
like 15 000 because i know my hooks good
you know what i'm saying
i know i mean i feel like if somebody's
gonna get something from you they should
get the hooks yeah you feel me yeah
so you know what i'm saying but a lot of
times like i do versus like for
for 10 if i'm in a city you know what
i'm saying uh
you know sometimes they want the verse
in the video i get like a 20 and make a
quick 20. so
like i and and that's how just doing
that
i ain't really never really did features
a lot like that so
when i went because i couldn't really
clear my own music and people having
problem getting clear when i was on the
label so when i got independent
everybody wanted cause people know i
make good music they know they're gonna
get
you know saying some good stuff out of
me and they know i've been around for a
long time and i'm
respected in it so people be paying
that's how you know i could i could go
if i really want to say
i i'm gonna get on my 12 bucks nothing
to leave for two weeks i'm gonna go to
four different cities you know saying i
know i could make 150 000
you know what i'm saying just off
creatures and features and videos you
know what i'm saying
all that money like not for nothing is
straight cash yeah and i be
you know what i've said and i just i go
and just cause like i said
my life i already set up like i own my
house
yeah so i just really put it all back in
music like i probably want to go
do something promote promotion wise you
know what i'm saying and that's the
sweet thing about being independent now
because
so if you get a billboard are you paying
for that out of your own pocket yeah i
mean like i'm i got i got a situation
with empire right now
shout out to gazzie and nema yeah
they're my people so right now
i'm the type of artist that i already
know is death so i spend it myself i
know i know it's the you know what i'm
saying and even if
you know even if i exhausted that budget
i still gonna spit myself because i just
believe in my stuff so much
and then i'm the type of artist where
like
i really enjoy being on the road people
know my music going
so i invest in myself you know so i go
you know what i'm saying do this let me
ask you this as somebody who
has been you know obviously i don't
think a lot of people knew about the
columbia's involvement yeah
but would you advise artists
to take a big advance when they do uh
sign a deal or do any sort of
distribution or would you advise them to
like
because you know at the end of the day
you got to pay that money back two times
to
to break even on it for the most part
would you advise somebody to take a big
bag because i think a lot of people like
yo i signed this
million dollar deal yeah but it's like
was it worth you like taking that
upfront money to just like
yeah you could or you could just get the
monthly yeah
it depends on your situation at the
moment though like you know it says you
are
if you coming like right now if somebody
come off me a million dollars
right now for for record deal i know
i'm not going to take it because you can
do that yeah because i can see the
amount of money i'm making
i see you know saying that what i'm
getting
from the people that i'm messing with
right now without even having to commit
so much you know what i'm saying like
you didn't do something with empire you
could do whatever you want yeah you feel
me so it's like
if you really know the game
somebody like empire gonna be your best
bit and i ain't just saying they kind of
signed an empire
right if you know the game because like
i said i say this in every interview
if you just through watch your time a
major i wanna say another sign to a
major label
if that's what it takes to get on your
feet as an artist do that sometimes you
gotta do what you gotta do yeah do what
you gotta do but while you in that deal
be listening learning what they do
making the connections that you know
what i say when you mean people don't
just
you know saying really meet people like
when you meet people they be introducing
you or you'll be around the people that
they hiring to
do this stuff so if you meet them people
once you do go independent
you got a good relationship you kind of
have an idea of infrastructure
yeah you know what i'm saying a lot of
times they're going to charge you
way cheaper than what they chuck what
they're doing
hey what you just said is like a lost
art form in the music game and that's
these
like i mean i see it as like being on
the radio side like
you'll meet an artist and you'll be like
damn that dude does not want to be here
like he's like a dick like you could
tell he's just like
yeah you know and and the thing is is
like that's fine yeah but like
building like genuine relationships and
like like you said when you meet
somebody like meet him don't be like yo
what's up fam yeah
because you never like you you never
know when you might you know what i'm
saying it'd probably be a
it'd probably be a little reporter that
was like you probably go somewhere
you probably had a intern in here you
know what i'm saying uh
five years from now who could that be
yeah yeah that intern can be somebody or
that intern can be he he could be the
the lead writer for this person i've
seen that [ __ ] happen all the time i
mean [ __ ] i used to i was an intern for
two years working for free yeah it's
like
they're gonna remember if you you know
they're gonna remember if you know i'm
saying how
respectful of an artist you was you know
saying that they genuinely
[ __ ] with you when they when they met
you type stuff like that so i'll be
keeping all that in mind like when i
meet people you know so i i actually i
genuinely
[ __ ] with people so uh i feel like just
throughout my career like
every everybody that i've met like i met
shirley wrote it loud when i was
signed with uh columbia you know what
i'm saying we just spoke briefly and
stuff like that but
uh you know once i got independent you
notice i still had no relationships to
be able to you know saying go back and
politic
woulda and stuff like that so now that
i'm independent i'm just moving way
way different i really feel like way
more
freer like it's a different piece of
mind they put you in a different music
space like
i can really drop whenever i want like
you know what's in and that's
like i could take longer drop or i could
drop back to back it's however i want to
do whatever you want to do
so yeah it's just a different space man
then
a lot of times like i said if y'all made
the connection they don't delay was
gonna kill you with them over here it's
like you're gonna be wondering like
oh yeah you're gonna be like why did i
pay yo the worst part i see is i see
like
like i have had friends signed and then
they'll get like an engineering
fee for making the clean version of
their album and it'll be like fifteen
thousand dollars
yeah like wait i paid some dude fifteen
grand to make the clean version of my
single like nobody's charging like
that's insane
but like you said like you just gotta
know anything you gotta be smart you got
no ways to filter that money
though also like you know a lot of
artists like
they'll they'll like let the student
like the label pick their studio and
then like you look and they're like wait
i spent two grand today in
studio time when i could have went and
like booked my own spot for like 500
yeah see i record my own i recorded all
like all my
songs i got plex and stuff i recorded
mixed and messed with all my own stuff
so
you you record mix master everything
yeah yeah i do i do everything
now i don't you know what i'm saying
right right
everything at home yeah i've recorded
everything like what's your like home
setup like
you know what was your mic like i had
the uh
newman mic i had the apollo you know
what's in the yamaha speakers right
the just the basics yeah the base the
basic a padded room
the basic stuff you know what i said
it's all really about your your presets
and
like i said i had a template you get
that little template and the engineer
put you on that template yeah that
engineer he put me on my tent he put me
on that template so
like what i was doing i was just
charging them for me recording myself so
that's how you feel tired you're
recording but you probably got a 150
recording budget you know saying if you
recording yourself
you know what i'm saying that's right
they're not in the studio more artists
should open their own studios
that's how you just gotta know your
contract though if you don't know your
country if you're like
especially you like if you ever like i i
know are you gonna end up
trying i got an artist yeah i got yeah i
gotta order i gotta order right now oh
name
uh brooklyn love i had another artist
before that but she
i uh i don't really mess with everyone
but i got an artist right now named
brooklyn love she uh she's
dope yeah nah she's from uh baltimore oh
[ __ ]
uh-huh that's wild shout out to
baltimore man yep
yo what's up man boulette kev here
shouting out to the homies at odd socks
for sponsoring the bootleg cab podcast
and showing us love man
and let me tell you something we don't
take everyone's money
that's not true we'll take everyone's
money but donald trump's but with that
being said we [ __ ] with odd socks all
right
um i've been rocking odd socks for like
eight years now
and um man christmas time coming up make
sure you get you some odd socks
first of all let's talk about these
basics right here
these joints are the most comfortable
socks i've ever put on my feet all right
no design
no license but just crazy so make sure
you get some of those
all right then they got the nickelodeon
they got the
scarface they got tapatio they got wwe
how about chef from southpaw you know
what i'm saying whatever you need shout
out stonecold steve austin by the way
these are the socks that i wear when i
uh
drink pbr and yell at my wife
uh anyway um shout out to old dirty
bastard too
go to oddssoxofficial.com right now
all right right now go to
oddssocksofficial.com use the keyword
bootleg kev
and you will receive 20 off at checkout
go do that
so the the the blue blue van dross 3 is
out
um what is like you said now you can
drop music whenever you want so like
what is your uh what's your plan for the
rest of the year man uh
i'm gonna drop uh i'm gonna drop love
scars
ep uh
in five days and five days on october
second uh
it's like one of them that's friday
that's like two days
oh yeah well look this is this will be
this will come out next week so this
will be
it's already out yeah yeah so uh love
scars
yeah and that's one like one of my uh
there's this real blue vegetarian
stuff so it's gonna be like a full
uh r b project uh
like when i drop them when i drop r b
projects they go they go crazy the
ladies love it man yeah
so i'm after i do that then i'm start
working on my first
real real new album yeah debut album
that i'm that i'm dropping uh
with uh we we're boosting them team
we're gonna get to working on uh
that first um after this after this
project truck
um what inspired you to get your own
tour bus
because that's another thing that you
said like you know
people got to start thinking this way
man nah man like for real though i
really
i really caught a steal like a blessing
on it because i uh
it was this australian guy and his his
daughter was
like a real fan of my music so uh i
went to nashville one time like i said i
treated everybody with yeah i treated i
just treated everybody with respect so
he ain't hit me up he was like man yeah
you know i do i do publishing and stuff
like that i was just like man yeah
you know uh let's talk about it so he
picked me up from the output
i went to his house and yeah big stupid
house you know what i'm saying so
end up coming to find out he ended up
being a
a singer from australia that had like
multiple number ones and stuff so he
owned a whole big
tour bus company and i was like man i
need i mean i need a toy bus you feel me
so uh he was like uh he was like man i i
get you one like you know what i'm
saying there's no problem
so uh yeah he gave me october
he gave you one yeah him oh yeah he gave
him a tour but
so um that's funny well you know what he
what he really did was
you might want to say he gave it to me
because i gave him 20 000 for it
but the turbo is worth like 200 000. you
know saying i gave him twenty thousand
four so [ __ ]
uh and after that you know saying i had
broke him on like
managing me for a little while you know
saying and uh stuff like that so it was
like
you know it was kind of he was letting
me use it you know saying while i was
managing and stuff but he had ended
you know getting into like some
multi-million
dollar deals with some stuff and you
know
we still keep in touch with he was just
like you know yeah ain't really so now
you rent the tour bus out to other
artists yeah
yeah i'll rent it out to other other
people man like uh it'd be artists
families
stuff like that you know what i'm saying
yeah so yeah
so uh yeah for real though
but i probably would eventually because
i got like sprinkles and stuff too so
i probably would eventually got my own i
just like how
it is you know what i'm saying it saved
me because it got like a whole
king bedroom in the back you know i'm
saying stuff like that so they saved me
for help to get rooms
if i want to go like out and just hit
city the city the city of the city and
make money you know i'm saying
i could go do it you know it's ain't
good because i'm just on a bus you know
what i'm saying what's your biggest
market besides uh
home like as far as like where you get
the most bread for a
show or you know streaming wise what do
you think is your biggest city
it'll probably be houston atlanta
and all of louisiana like
anywhere in louisiana i'm gonna get a
bag like houston
dallas you know say uh
milwaukee uh
new jersey like you know i think i got
he's really like spaced out like a weird
like you know saying weird places but
mostly the south
like anywhere in the south like they go
they don't know me but like
it'd be surprising okay anyway i go like
somebody gonna know me i could be in
omaha nebraska god damn like somebody
gonna be like oh you blew you know
saying that's how i know like you said a
good thing like
my music way more popular than me
like more people know my music and they
know me just because like
like i said i don't really be you know i
don't really do too many interviews for
real like that
i just really started doing interviews
like that but uh
yeah but i like it like that though
because like i said
you get built up in the blog like people
want to see that [ __ ]
all the time and then when they don't
see it uh
you fell off you know what i'm saying so
no i think too it's like if you set an
expectation
yeah you have to be this person on
social media yeah
and then like you got to keep trying to
outdo yourself with the dumb [ __ ]
yeah i feel like like someone like
little pump is in that space yeah we're
like
we kind of knew a little pump for being
like this wild ass kid yeah
but like what happens when the wild ass
kid [ __ ] goes away
yeah it's like you know what she's with
the same thing with the cashier like the
cash
yes he brought more than that he
probably sitting back just planning
ten more things he can he could do he's
gotta out dude
he's gotta outdo the disrespect yeah
it's like okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna go on this disrespect tour
before my album comes out go to la go to
chicago shoot videos and all these
places where i shouldn't be
and it's like okay now what yeah that's
two there that's two that's two that's
too much for me i just like
i just enjoyed i was just enjoying uh
who are some of your peers that you're
uh like fans of musically because
there's a lot of dope dope
dope artists right now especially that
do the melodic [ __ ] uh
like i really mess with all of them like
i i tell them you know when i'm driving
i listen to all that music like you know
what i'm saying
i missed broadway like i knew roy when
his come up like
you know what i'm saying no he's been
bubbling at it i mean he's been doing
this thing for for some years too i feel
like you guys
i feel like he was born well that's
crazy because
well like if you go look at his uh hard
on ice video like
i was in like that was when he was out
there like man do a drop do a drop flip
i'm like yeah
i messed with him like he was i think he
was opening up for me in a show in
florida
and then after that like i think he i
don't know if he redid a deal with alamo
or what
after that he just started going crazy
you know what you're not he's dope man
he's fire i think like uh i mean we
talked about clever clever is really
yeah incredible have you have you i like
pardoning it i like part in this dodo
that's probably my favorite order
he's one of the hardest writers ever
yeah have you heard blast from l.a
um you know one of my one of my uh
one of my female friends uh
she just interviewed him uh do you know
tally tally spencer
okay yeah yeah she just interviewed him
so that's that's how i heard him and
then i started getting into
he's fired no i just think it's still
man i just think that like you know
it's it's it's a good place where music
is
because you know three four years ago it
was like that over modulated soundcloud
[ __ ]
yeah like it was just a lot of like it
just like music
wasn't and that's crazy is that you were
making like melodic dope [ __ ] when that
wasn't even the wave
yeah and the sound just came to you yeah
yeah so that's just dope man
so um love scars
debut album is your debut album
when you like like do you consult with
boozy on that [ __ ] like hey let's
cause i know you said you're gonna work
you know get get with
his team on that like yeah like oh i
mean a recent conversation we just had
you know
saying you know he wanted to be involved
more because like i said it's just been
kind of chaotic just me getting out the
label situation and
getting uh with the new thing so we
really have time to just sit down and
really just
plan plot and strategize on a game plan
so this
probably be the first time we had since
you know i signed my new situation
uh and you know this would be the first
time for real
yeah i saw he signed you know it's crazy
the last time i saw boozy
uh he brought the little twelve-year-old
kid he's with what's his name
um do you like how how's your
relationship like with other artists
under the under the umbrella that you
know because boozy's going oh yeah i
mean i met a lot of them uh og dre
uh d rogers uh nina
uh juicy oh i missed raleigh we are we
all cool like i said
i feel like uh you know saying
a lot of them you know saying go get get
ready
you know they catch away be will uh
you know like i said everybody like
timing and everything like i said i
i've been doing eight nine years
before i you know what i'm saying really
just thought no for sure man you know
what i'm saying
just just moving like i'm moving now so
you know it all just come with time and
persistence for real like
are you um i know you you know you're
expecting a trial then is that your
first baby uh no no no i got
how many kids you have i got three now
this is this would be number four number
nine
number three number three yeah um you're
with your lady too right
yeah how is it is it um well we we
we kind of we kind of we kind of broke
up right now kind of single right now
i'll be fine
she's about to have your child yeah
trust me my wife hasn't talked to me in
like six days yeah
i got marriage counseling tomorrow but
no but
i guess i guess is it is it is it hard
because you know i feel like when you're
somebody like you especially you make
love music that
females love is it tough to be in a
relationship
uh yeah cause sometimes you know saying
people
like ain't gonna lie like
the reason why you know i dropped this
um because
you know i like i like i have to really
to make a really
perfect album uh i have to really
go through something you feel me so
that's why it's kind of like a random
album because like
you got to go through life yeah i had i
had to really go through it
you know what i'm saying so that's why
the music be hitting them so hard cause
like
it'd be real stuff you know what i'm
saying so uh
they be liking when i'm heartbroken
when's the last time you cried man
i ain't crying a little minute though i
ain't gonna lie i ain't crying in a
minute probably last time i cried with
uh no problem
uh when villa died my homework
that probably like a year ago yeah i
ain't crap
i don't really cry like that for real
like that i'd be saying that's the
therapy
yeah i'd be mad but i don't really cry
like that for real
look that the project is out um go
register to vote
mm-hmm so yeah yeah definitely
definitely go to russia you got to get
your vote in bro alabama is
one of them ones where your vote counts
oh yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna go
if you lived in l.a i'd be like you know
what dude like i just don't be anytime
somebody president i personally just
don't be feeling a fix
of what they what they do you know what
i'm saying but i know some people do so
you know i'm saying
that's you know i'm playing my part in
you know i'm saying but
uh you know i just i just really been
been on the go so much i ain't really
know too much about the voting how to
how to do it
that i mean that's really what i think
they need to do like put more education
on
how to even get involved in voting
because i ain't got a lot a lot of
people what do you do
like how do you vote like where do you
guys just show up yeah like a lot of
people from where i'm from they don't
even know
how to vote like they don't even know
like no billboards
telling you the steps how to get unless
you just
now you're right yeah this is this
problem i think it's uh
you know unfortunately it's kind of hey
i bet you you paid more in taxes than
donald trump did though right
yeah ain't no i mean but only like i
ain't fine i don't think
like you haven't filed taxes once
but you know what like hey that's okay
because all that feature money you don't
go i gotta count it i
gotta though like i i got my stuff on
tabs like for the last three years i
just haven't found it yet you know what
i'm saying you gotta fight that they
gonna crack you for them penalties
yeah i probably i feel like like i said
like i i mean i got hey [ __ ] it the
president i really really
had a lot of music expenses like i'd
invested
so much the president's not paying taxes
why should you man
that man pay 750 one thing about music
though everything
is an investment like this juror
investment like this
what what what i what everything let me
know so
when you say this jewelry is an
investment i feel like
most people would say that artists [ __ ]
up by getting to
jewelry yeah you know what i'm saying
like it's a mistake
yeah when you say it's an investment
what do you mean
uh i i see it as like
in in the
the way of that's how you can sell it
you know that's how you can sell it to
uh the the people the irs you know
it is because it can be looked at as an
investor oh i see what you're saying so
like
the irs you could be like this was you
know wardrobe yeah
it is yeah it it actually is you know
what it says
you can write off your jewelry expenses
yeah that's [ __ ] great
yeah i feel like it's a crop for a music
video yeah you know what i'm saying but
i feel like a lot of artists it is like
a symbol to them
like jury really like you know what i'm
saying for
because you have a screen yeah yeah like
for screen [ __ ] like druid like is a
a trophy like it's like a trophy ain't
really nothing to
say um this or that it's just like a
trophy like okay i mean i made it this
far man i deserve a chain i deserve some
time
i want to shine like i want to shine i
want to shine bright i want to be
seen because i've been slipped on and
people to
you know saying then throw the rug up
over me so so long for so many years
i'm getting money you know i want people
to see me it's kind of like a trophy
like a you know saying
type type of death now that makes sense
i mean yeah i just think
some people just like the way it looks
would you judge somebody if you found
out that they
had fake jewelry uh nah because i used
to effect you
i used to affect jerry back in the day
like you know especially now i feel like
you could get those lab created diamonds
yeah yeah yeah i used to affect your
back in the day so
you know what i'm saying i feel like man
you just got to be real with yourself
man everybody threw on something for
everybody
doing something fake before they made it
you know what i'm saying just like i
said you got to speak on stuff before it
happened like you got to speak on
something for whatever
ain't like i was saying it was real if
i'm lying about it
if i just got on some fake jury and you
know what i'm saying
and you just see me with it on and i
ain't saying nothing about it i just
back when i was young coming up you know
what i'm saying 16 17 then
that was just me at the time you know
what i'm saying like i'm saying
oh this real i'm capping then yeah but
if you assume it's fake and you tell me
it's [ __ ]
like you know what i'm saying so what
but uh
yeah man like oh yeah i won't really
judge nobody but that's fair
what's the dumbest thing you've ever
purchased or like the biggest purchase
you've made that you regret
uh i bought man i bought i bought so
many cars
i bought some in the car man what's the
most expensive car you bought
oh i bought a lambo uh
for like 150. [ __ ] about a corvette for
70.
uh 150 on the lambo yeah
you said you got past that wave though
right huh yeah you're like yo i i got
i got through that part of life yeah i
got through that part of life yeah
i i really i spent a lot of money on
clothes like
i used to wear a lot of like design and
stuff like that but i mean you do have
gucci socks on right now
yeah but i i used to wear a lot of it
though like i used to go spend like ten
thousand
you know what i'm saying just on some
[ __ ] clothes
yeah but now i just be like man i got a
hundred fifty thousand worth of jury
like what i what [ __ ]
these yeah did you ever did you ever
wear those chunky ass shoes
yeah yeah well i still i still sometimes
like i
get to feel like it'll be like certain
occasion though like if i know i'm gonna
go make
25 uh i just feel like those shoes were
so i'm glad they they're kind of gone i
know some people still wear them but
[ __ ] man they're like everybody had that
well like when you when you come from
nothing man it's just like
when you come from nothing and you dream
about all these things
you know what i'm saying growing up get
them got the little race cars the
lamborghini the buildings and stuff like
that when you finally get the money
you gonna explore and see what they feel
like you know what i'm saying you gonna
just because it's just like a
you always wanted to do this stuff like
you always wanted to you always
looked at the bt one off sister parker
saw
saw your people with the chains on and
the fast card with the girl
so if you making it like you gonna try
that out like okay well nobody say you
gonna try that you're gonna see what
that's like
now is you smart enough to stop is the
question you know what i'm saying stop
when you you know say when they come to
that time and realize okay
it's over for this like i gotta go
handle stuff that's important that's
gonna
make me good forever like if if you
can't understand when it's that point
then it's okay you know what i'm saying
do you feel like you got um
you got snubbed for the freshman cover
it just happened
yeah no i i feel like i got snubbed for
the one before that because at that
moment like i had
you know said two workers that had just
went gold you know what i'm saying
i was getting more for shows than
probably every artist oh
that they had oh no you know saying
probably just some of the main screen
artists but
uh yeah i just felt like i was just
slept on but like i said i was the only
one for alabama like they ain't really
believing that in that way but like most
of them are zoned out they ain't have no
[ __ ]
gold rocket no i feel like yeah there's
there was a lot of people who got
snubbed this year
i felt like you were one of them i felt
like you know yeah
so don toliver could have been on there
yeah i ain't even put in my i ain't
gonna lie and he put him i pitched this
i didn't even put in my pistol oh cause
you're supposed to pitch yourself
yeah you want to pitch yourself but i
feel like i've been doing this for too
long
you know what i'm saying i would i would
have liked it but i ain't really
tripping
too much everybody man what is um
give me your top three or four albums of
all time because you have a pretty
eclectic sound i feel like you know it
might be
[Music]
get richer that trend solid uh
tupac uh i got i ain't gonna lie
it's a couple of tupac albums that i
feel like it's all eyes on me me against
the world
yeah yeah um
boost it for my thugs uh
uh then lauren hill album
miss education you have the music
education alarm here classic
would you do the acon record right now
if he wanted to do a record with you
even though he he did the 69 feature
uh i mean i probably you know saying
i look at everything from uh from
a moral standpoint and i probably
wouldn't
you know what i'm saying just because i
feel like
you know i don't stand for it or i'm
pretty much sure he'll probably be
profitable like i said i mean at the
same time
like a legend like of course i'd like to
do one but i just can't
yeah yeah i just yeah i'm i feel like
if if feminine morals that he stand
on you know saying then you probably
pass yeah i'll probably pass you know
not take nothing away from him you know
what i'm saying just
you know i like i said i don't i don't
really do stuff for the money i do stuff
i want to do it because like i like i
said i'm straight so
really too much too much let me ask you
being in mississippi
how much [ __ ] crazy trump [ __ ] do you
have to deal with
in mississippi oh i don't deal with that
like i'm
i imagine there's like trump flags
flying everywhere maggot hats every
[ __ ]
for the most part they had like i said
like being like
believe it or not being racist ain't
really popular like he's not really
popular like that he's not hope not
yeah it's not really a popular
perception you know what i'm saying
it's more it's more people i ain't gonna
say it's not
more non-racist people than racist
people but it's more people that
don't show their racism than and they
yeah you know what i'm saying because
it's like it's frowned upon like you
lose your job you can lose
it's a lot oh yeah yeah [ __ ]
most companies want to appeal to the
black people because we spend the most
money
well yeah plus if you say some wild [ __ ]
online most yo these
like you'll lose your job yeah okay
they're gonna sacrifice
they're gonna sacrifice you instead of
using losing the whole black community
because the
black community going we're gonna spend
we're gonna spend that money every day
so it's like you
it's either you're gonna sacrifice this
one person or you're gonna sacrifice
this whole
community you know what i'm saying so
yeah i already see too much plus i stay
way out on
on my own uh playing probably probably
look like i'm out of
my own city yeah they're only seven
acres seven yeah oh salute man shout out
to
yo that's that's a beautiful thing well
look get your ep
is it ep uh yeah it's the ep it's on six
songs yeah
that's out and um hopefully the debut
album will be out as well yeah
you know go get this guy when he opens
his hookah spot go get some [ __ ]
hookah oh yeah yeah we're gonna have to
and the food truck too
is the food truck still open uh yeah
yeah the food truck the food truck
uh i just got something fixed on the
truck so it's gonna go into
it's gonna hit the streets like in like
a week so i'm gonna get
like a whole chain open for real so i'm
like boom
yeah i appreciate your time man yep oh
good good